[Musique]
pour la quatrième année consécutive le
collège jean des sme organise le
concours d'éloquence
cette édition fait discourir les élèves
sur le thème de l' estime de soi vous
allez me dire que normalement il faut
partager
oui mais attention même si on n'a pas
confiance en soi et ben on risque de se
dire que nous eh ben on va pas y arriver
est ce que j'ai dit et je me suis du
genre moi j'ai raconté que la première
fois que j'étais amoureux d'une fille
belle fait que je prends mon courage à
deux mains sinon bah j'aime mes enfants
donne quoi ah je n'ai pas fait j'aurais
dû faire mieux que non il faut que tu
fais si tu as quelque chose à dia
quelqu'un dit le bas ce que sinon tu vas
te ment fondre jusqu'à très longtemps
alors c'est vrai que j'avais jamais eu
l'occasion d'assister à un concours
d'éloquence je suis très étonné est
vraiment très satisfaite de voir la
qualité des présentations des candidats
et je trouve ça vraiment bien que les
élèves puissent justement apprendre sur
ce fusé sur ce sujet qu'elle estime de
soi cinquante six orateurs vont
intervenir individuellement ou par
groupe
l'équipe éducative à accompagner ces
jeunes dans leur réflexion
donc on a commencé par travailler
sur la signification du mot estime et
soit donc commencer vraiment par le
dictionnaire
qu'est-ce que ça évoque chez les lèvres
travailler vraiment sûr se sont
ressentis au travail etc surtout en
forme de nuage de mots de cartes aux
risques heuristique pour permettre
vraiment de construire les différentes
parties du discours
le département de la réunion encourage
ce concours dans le cadre des aides aux
projets culturels attribué à l'ensemble
des établissements scolaires du
secondaire
[Musique]